good morning believe nation today's
message is do what you love over to you
Ivanka Trump I look around at my
girlfriends and my my guy friends and
they're in jobs that they don't really
have a lot of growth potential in that
they're not passionate about and I think
if we're ever going to make bold
decisions it has to be at this point in
our life you know we have to be out
there we have to be experimenting we
have to be looking for that which makes
us tick and I think a big part of that
evolution for me was really summer jobs
and working and making sure to actually
you know get into the world and try
different things and eliminate those
which is as useful eliminating those
career paths that you're not interested
in as it is you know doing things that
that do interest you but I think just
being bold and and taking risks when
you're young is so important because I
can't imagine working the hours that I
do if I didn't fundamentally love it and
I think that's the difference between
somebody's successful and somebody
that's extremely successful somebody
that's good and somebody that's
exceptionally good it's the level of
drive which directly stems from passion
so this message has to be the most
repeated message that I hear over and
over and over and over again from people
who have had success and success in
general not just as entrepreneurs I
started off this channel only focusing
on entrepreneurs and we branched out and
we've looked at athletes and we've
looked at musicians we've looked at
singers we've look at artists who've
looked at inventors and consistently
across everybody who's reached the top
of their game the thing that they always
say always is you have to do what you
love to do something that I love doing I
love building teams love the process of
solving the problems that's how much
love I have for this thing that I do I
love every minute of it really love to
do you didn't Bob and things that you
love you're so passionate excited and in
love with and you may have heard that
message before and you may say that
that's boring
it's not interesting and I already know
that Evan what are you doing it because
the next part comes in - how do I find
what I'm passionate about how do I find
the thing that I love and this is where
so many people fall down you find what
you love by exploring by testing by
trying by when you get an idea for
something you don't sit on it for five
years and hope one day it's gonna happen
you find some small way to get started
anything an idea pops into your head
find a small way to get started and see
if it makes you come alive or not if you
want to open a snowboarding school maybe
you should learn how to snowboard first
right and you can go and learn how to
snowboard right now go pick up a
snowboard rent it go take a lesson and
see does it make you come alive do you
want to keep doing this thing or not
instead of making this list of all these
things that one day you're gonna get to
and never do because what ends up
happening is you settle you settle you
have ideas for what to do you never
actually go out and do a lot of them and
what you're in is okay that's pretty
good
the enemy of greatness is not crap it is
not terrible the enemy of brightness is
good your situation right now yeah it
could be better but it could be a lot
worse - you're good you're good so you
don't have the hustle and drive to go
for great that's where a lot of people
fall down I like to say that the
greatest basketball player of all time
is not Michael Jordan it's not Wilt
Chamberlain it's somebody who we've
never heard of the greatest basketball
of all time is a manager at Starbucks
because he never picked up a basketball
because he never knew that he had that
talent that passion that ability because
they didn't try because he settled too
soon he settled too early for okay and
he lives an okay life instead of having
Michael Jordan level talent and
dominated industry you have the ability
to dominate an industry you have Michael
Jordan level talent at something that
you will wake up every day and want to
crush and go and practice and take shot
after
shot after shot and watch tape and be
obsessed with you have that for
something and if it's not for what
you're doing right now then stop
settling stop mailing it in stop being
okay with an okay life you could do more
and not just for yourself you could do
more to contribute to your family to
contribute to your community to
contribute to your country to help the
world with something you have that
ability that talent inside you and what
are you doing with it if you are not
that obsessed about what you're doing
right now I'm not saying drop it
immediately and just float and hope
something comes but you've had ideas
right you've had ideas of things to do
stop sitting on them try it out I never
thought I would own the largest salsa
dance studio maybe in the world I never
thought it I never thought about salsa
dancing at all but I went to a salsa
club and I liked it and I wanted to
learn more and I wanted to do it again
and do it again and practice and get
better and improve one thing led to
another and here we are that's a story
of a lot of entrepreneurs if you have an
idea for something you owe it to
yourself to give it a shot to try it to
take some small step and move it forward
and you may try it and hate it and
that's great information all you may try
it and love it and want to come back and
do it again and do it again and do it
again and if you find that thing that
you want to just keep doing and keep
grinding and keep getting better at and
keep improving and keep helping others
with that's the thing that you could
have Michael Jordan level talent at and
you owe it to yourself to go for it so
the question of the day two parts one
first part if you know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at I want
you to leave it in the comments below
part two if you don't know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at I want
you to write down three things that
you're going to start to explore this
week now you've had ideas on and you
haven't done yet and you're gonna try it
out this week three ideas leave it in
the comments below
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Scott Stokes from Swain Woodham code NZ
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book Scott your one word it really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso hey believe
nation we're also looking at doing a top
ten rules for success for Ivanka here is
a sneak peek at some of the clips that
we're looking at I hope you enjoy the
bonus I think the only way to build
confidence is through trial and error I
think when you're young one of the
challenges is that you're insecure about
knowing nothing and you think people
expect you to have all the answers now
as a 34 year old I'm okay with not
having all the answers I recognize
there's a lot I don't know and I own
that and I love that and it makes me
curious and and helps me continue to
grow that's why I always tell people
just get out and do things you have to
learn through trial and error and you
have to just try and every time you try
something you get a little bit more
experience a little bit more wisdom you
build it a little bit more confidence so
to all of you young people just get out
there start doing things take risks just
just try I asked all the women that I
interview can women truly have it all
because when someone looks at your life
from the outside in your mother your
wives your real estate developer you
have a full-time job but you have
another full-time job because you also
have a very successful clothing and
accessories business so it seems like
you have it all but do you think women
really can have it all I think it's a
very difficult question
and it's one that I try not to answer
for other people because I think by its
nature what is having it all me it means
different things to different people you
know for me it's it's very important to
have a family but it's also very
important to be professionally fulfilled
for some people one of those is
important than the other isn't so you
know I think you have to figure out what
your priorities are and in life are and
then architect your life around those
priorities I think when people start to
get lost it's when their lives are
grossly inconsistent with their value
set and and their core priorities so for
me you know at the end of every week I
sort of do a self-assessment of did I
spend my time in the right way was I
where I needed to be you know it's there
are some days it's okay to not be home
for dinner if I have a big deal my
priority may be that for that moment of
time but I also know if my child ever
gets sick if anything happens well there
goes every other priority so I think
it's it's always a balance and you just
have to do the best you can do